35 years after his death a final goodbye
to tomasanka and 12 of his companions
who are being laid to rest at a memorial
in wagadugu Sankar a pan-africanist
revolutionary who was also a feminist
and an environmentalist he sought to
lift his people out of poverty and
emancipate them from what he saw as the
shackles of the former colonial power
France
he is being buried where he was
assassinated this will help revive the
Revolution and keep his legacy alive
after the tragic death a court last year
convicted several military commanders in
sankara's closest friend former
president bless compare for their role
in the assassination the trial started
after France agreed to release secret
documents but the court failed to
determine whether France had any
involvement in sankara's Murder
the burial comes days after Burkina Faso
Junta severed military ties with France
hundreds of French special forces were
asked to leave the country on Sunday
Ibrahim trari who took power in a coup
last year blames France for heavy losses
in the battlefield the country faces a
surge of attacks from armgroups linked
to Al-Qaeda and isil many of the
fighters are villagers from the north of
Burkina Faso turning against their
government draari is trying to associate
himself with the memory of Sankara in an
effort to unite the country
when you carry a weapon that can kill
and you're in uniform you need to
understand the implications and
responsibilities so many soldiers are on
the battlefields committing crimes
without understanding that they are
fighting men and women who perhaps
aspire to the same common ideals
Sankara a soldier who was also regarded
as a messenger for peace unity and
compassion many in his now divided
country want to see those ideals revived
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera